buddhist advice is it's something that
is easily returnable
so if it doesn't work they return it
no harm done a little more gratuitous
advice
birthday coming up one of my daughters
called me this morning said what do you
want for your birthday i said that's
up to you but not a sweater
or a tie which i consider default
gifts the default gifts
person can't figure out what to get you
what did they get you
sweater or a tie no sweaters or ties
holiday season is 37 days we talked
about thanksgiving
it's not about thanksgiving thanksgiving
is the commencement
of a holiday season and it goes from
thanksgiving to both thanksgiving to
black friday
to commencement of holiday parties to
commencement of holiday travel
the commencement of holiday celebrations
that is 37 days up to
new year's day and i see that is one
period of time that is a period of
increased social activity increased
social activity
will increase the infection rate my
opinion
personal opinion is that you're going to
see the
increased continue all
through the holidays
you'll see it continue through
january 2nd and then the lag
for the testing hospitalization which
takes you to about mid-january
question is how fast do the cases
increase nobody can tell you because it
depends on what people do
it is up to us there is no predetermined
fate it is a pure function of what new
yorkers do
it's a pure function of social action
what can government do during this
period we can warn people we can educate
people
we can enforce restrictions we can do
testing and tracing what is the biggest
fear
the biggest fear is overwhelming the
hospitals period
that's where we are and that is
a serious serious concern we announced a
five-point plan the other day
i'm sure you all recorded it to memory
but for those of you who were out sick
first was managing the hospital system
manage the load of the hospital system
we know
the capacity of hospitals 54 000
statewide we know it by region
manage that load increase and balance
the testing it's a lot of demands on
testing
you have to test test nursing homes you
have to test
essential workers you have to attend
test
business professionals who have licenses
who have to be tested as part of their
work
you want to be fair in balancing that
testing
keep schools open k-8
positivity rate in schools is amazingly
low
and shows that the schools are much
safer
environments than the surrounding
communities both for the teachers and
for the students
small gatherings are now the number one
cause for spread and that's new and that
is different
and the public has to understand that
fifth get ready for the vaccine
distribution
we hope for flattening of the increase
in the january we hope
that the increase in social activity is
through through the holidays
after january 2nd people settle down the
social activity slows down the travel
slows down
and the increase in the rate slows down
okay then what happens after january 2nd
we then turn to how effective is the
vaccination program going to be
because the vaccination program is
really the end
game here right and there are big
questions on that
uh how fast does the vaccination program
go into effect how fair is the
vaccination program how inclusive is it
uh how many people partake
in the vaccination and
how much does the federal government
provide
to for a state to actually do
the vaccine and the percent of pop
participation you have a very high
skepticism rate
about this vaccine specifically you have
a high
skepticism rate about vaccines in
general
remember what we went through with the
measles vaccine
where you had a lot of parents who just
did not want their children
vaccinated for measles there's a whole
anti-vaxx movement of people who are
are skeptical about vaccines on top of
that you have
added skepticism about this vaccine
how long is the plateau how long
is the drop on the other side
depends on the vaccine production
and delivery schedule
and the effectiveness of it when do you
get back to the normal economy
experts will say you need 75 to 85
percent
of the population vaccinated
that is a tremendously high percentage
on every level administration
of it and acceptance
of it there is a range
of when the experts will say you can get
to that point
some say as soon as june
some say not until september
again nobody knows because there are too
many variables
it may also vary state to state
depending on how well that state does
and depending
on the receptivity of that state's
population
on the vaccines we've spoken to the fda
dr hahn is the commissioner of the fda
the we have a new york panel
the new york panel will review the fda's
approval
why because we know we have
existing skepticism about the vaccine
our panel did not create the skepticism
the skepticism existed and that's why we
created the review panel
kaiser poll says 60
of americans are skeptical about the
vaccine approval process
kaiser is not a political organization
pew poll
says about 50 percent of americans are
skeptical
about the vaccine that is very very
troubling
because if people think the vaccine
approval process was politicized
they're going to be less likely to take
the vaccine
you saw the numbers we need to
participate
you need 75-80 percent if you start with
a public
where 50 are skeptical about the vaccine
that's a major problem to combat
that problem about seven states
said i understand you're cynical and
skeptical
about this administration's approval
process
we'll set up a new york panel california
panel
to review the approval to help
build confidence and to
counter that existing cynicism right
uh it's not that
the state's panels created the cynicism
the cynicism created the state's panels
the fda and this administration
created the cynicism what happened on
hydroxychloroquine
created the cynicism the overt
political influence that this
administration has
shown repeatedly
that has been imposed on public health
officials
created the cynicism
so it is real and it exists and every
poll
has said the same thing we've also
spoken to cdc dr robert redfield
he we communicated to him and i believe
uh he understands this has to be an
inclusive process
the black brown and poor community has
paid the highest price for covet
why because it exposed an inherent
discrimination in our health care system
they live in communities with less
access to health care
they had a higher level of pre-existing
conditions
blacks died at twice the rate
of whites browns died at one and a half
times the rate of whites
covet testing was at a lower level
in the black brown and poor community
i'm not going to enhance
and aggravate the discrimination that
has already been
manifested by now
excluding them or discriminating against
them
in the vaccination process new york
state
will not do that i believe it's
unconstitutional i believe it's illegal
i believe the vaccine should be made
available to everyone
regardless of race income religion
etc and we know
that the black brown and poor community
has already paid
a disproportionate price
for this covert virus and we know
the black brown and poor community
[Music]
made up a majority of the essential
workers
who we relied on to do
the most important work for us all
through this
we also know that if you don't have
the full participation of the black
brown and poor communities
you're never going to hit the goal of 75
to 85
and that means the vaccination process
will fail
for all new yorkers and all americans
we also know that you can't dissuade the
undocumented population
from participating federal guidance
has states signing something called a
data sharing agreement
federal government suggests we identify
recipients by using social security
number
passport number or driver's license id
number those are also proxies
to determine citizenship
the federal agreement then says they can
share that information with
other federal agencies that triggers
ice and homeland security
we have lived this fight in new york
with the trusted traveler program and
the driver's license
program where we know
they were trying to get our list
to have ice use it
for enforcement actions and the third
variable is going to be the vaccine
funding
i'm working with the national governors
association
the federal government is not providing
any funding to speak of
for the states to do the vaccinations
who's supposed to pay for this
how am i supposed to do the distribution
we have a deficit from covid
uh you have local governments who are
starving and may lay off
essential workers those are the
essential workers you need to do the
vaccine program
this vaccine administration could cost
the state a billion dollars
the federal government has not provided
funding to states
anywhere near the amount i've also been
speaking to
congressional leaders across the board
senate leaders across the board if they
do a package
there has to be funding to administer
the vaccines it's not enough to say
we'll deliver them to your state
that's very nice fedex
can deliver them to the state
how do we then distribute it how do we
do the outreach how do we do the public
education how do we convince
85 percent of the people to take the
vaccine how do we get into public
housing how do we get into black and
brown communities
who's going to do this and who's going
to pay for it
yesterday the cdc's advisory committee
on
immunization practices issued formal
prioritization recommendations they
recommended frontline healthcare workers
and elderly people living in long-term
care facilities
that recommendation coincides
with the priorities that we had
established
already so the cdc's recommendation
reinforces the priorities we established
the first vaccine delivery to new york
will be 170
000. the federal government distributes
the vaccine
by percentage of population of that
state
so state's population divided by
available dosages
is what the state gets
there's no discretion in
how much the state gets it's purely a
percent of population
which is what they say at least
we expect if all safety and efficacy
approvals are granted
those doses will arrive on december 15th
by the end of december uh the
administration
suggests that there'll be enough to
vaccinate 20 million people with
two dosages which is 40 million dosages
uh that means six percent of americans
gives you an idea of where we're going
to be
coming into january uh and those six
percent
will be prioritized as the health care
workers
uh seniors in congregate facilities etc
but six percent of americans
uh having available dosages
by the beginning of january you see how
far we have to go
new york state also expects additional
allocation of the pfizer vaccine
and the moderna vaccine which has also
been
approved and we expect them later this
month
we're going to have to undertake two
operations simultaneously
one is the hospital management situation
which is critical
we have to reduce the spread we have to
reduce the number of people going into
hospitals
and we have to manage that patient
load going into hospitals we don't want
the hospitals overwhelmed
that is job one at the same time you
have the vaccine management program
the vaccine management program we need
the federal funding
we need a real aggressive outreach
effort we need social acceptance and
confidence to take the vaccine
this is going to be the largest
governmental
operation not just through covid
this will be the largest governmental
operation undertaken
since world war ii in my opinion
to give you an idea of how massive this
is
i said this to president-elect biden at
an
nga meeting this nation
has done about 130
covid tests over the past nine months
130 million from day one of covid
we have to do 330 million vaccines
twice how long does that take you
this state more testing than any state
in the united states
we have done just about the population
of the state
doing everything we could and that's
taken us nine months to do a covet test
and a cova test very few people refuse a
covet test
it's not a frightening test it's a nasal
swab
now you're asking a person to take two
vaccines
and you're asking them to take two
vaccines
which is a more elaborate medical
process and they're distrusting about
the vaccine
going in so this is going to be an
incredibly challenging period
uh to undertake both of these at the
same time
we are going to bring back a former
secretary to the governor larry schwartz
who came and helped us out
at the heat of the pandemic you can see
by his face that he's very happy to come
back
the joy that is on his face and his
willingness to come back and participate
larry was former secretary to me former
secretary to
governor patterson deputy county
executive west chester deputy county
executive
suffolk he's probably one of the most
skilled
government officials i've ever worked
with he ran the surge in flex program
uh the ppe shortage program the first
time around so he's going to come back
and help
linda lacewell is going to come back
simonita sebotik
is going to come back they help them the
first time around
you can see they're also happy to come
back they're also very big with hand
gestures
both of them if you notice
which is a good way to communicate using
the hands i use hand gestures also but
they were very helpful in the first
tranche
and i thank them for coming back and
helping again
um we're going to have a this is a
period where we need the public
to understand the changing dynamics
uh and how this uh this
covet is now spreading and how dangerous
a period we're in with hospitalization
so we're going to
going to do briefings every monday
wednesday friday and we'll start that
next week
these are the numbers for today
micro cluster zone 5.8 statewide
positivity 4.2
overall positivity with the micro
cluster is 4.6
193 000 tests 69
new yorkers passed away they're in our
thoughts and prayers
3 900 hospitalizations that's up 150
742 icu 373
intubations you can see
the we're looking at this now by region
the regional increase over the last
three weeks
and you see the same basic curve
on every region of the state first time
around
we had a new york city downstate long
island was just a problem
that was actually beneficial in a way
because we could bring resources from
upstate to help downstate
we don't have that option here
because you see that the
increase is statewide uh these are the
charts that we're going to focus on
going forward
this is the increase in hospitalizations
by percentage
okay uh highest
increase in hospitalizations western new
york
mohawk valley then finger lakes then
long island
then central new york mid hudson new
york city capital region north country
southern tier
by percentage and those are alarming
percentages
uh and we take that into consideration
by number of cases
the prioritization shifts
for obvious reasons uh by number of
cases it's new york city first
600 additional hospitalizations over
three weeks
then long island 366
western new york 307. now if you
adjust for population you see long
island city is very high
long island is very high western new
york is very high mid hudson is very
high by population
and it's important to see it both ways
because remember the hospital capacity
is roughly relative to the population
of the region so new york city is up 600
yes but new york city has many more
hospital beds
so you have to look at the percentage
increase and you also have to look at
the number of cases
bad news we have another mountain
i know how much you like mountains i've
heard many of your comments
about the mountains i may make another
mountain
to symbolize the mountain because i know
you like it
that's the bad news we have another
mountain to climb
the good news is the goal line is in
sight
and the goal line is a vaccine
that we administer that people accept
that could happen as early as june
could happen as late as september
depends on us
depends on us how many people goes in go
into the hospital
depends on us how many people get
vaccinated
how quickly more good news
new york is starting in a much better
place than the other states
we are just starting at a much better
place
we have a lower percentage of
hospitalizations lower percentage of
hospitalization
increase less
burden on our hospitals
pro rata less of a hospital emergency
than the other states because new
yorkers have been smart
they did the best job in the country
first time around
going from the highest infection rate to
the lowest infection rate
and i have no doubt if we do what we
have to do
new yorkers will handle this surge
better
than any state in the country i also
think
new york state is going to be stronger
and better
for it i know that you don't see it now
but this has been a global period of
disruption
people say well when are we going back
to normal you're not going back to
normal
life doesn't go backwards life goes
forward
the question is who finds the
opportunity
in this period of disruption you're
going to have new business practices
you're going to have new housing
practices you're going to have different
development
patterns there is opportunity
for the entrepreneurial
economy and entrepreneurial government
that seizes those changes
and that's what new york will do because
new yorkers
are tough smart united disciplined and
loving
questions oh i'm sorry i'm sorry before
we do questions
we have a psa that we want to show you
uh which is uh going to try to talk
about the new situation
with covid and how it's changing do you
want to run the psa
covet hospitalizations are climbing
nationwide
what can you do to stay safe be careful
in small gatherings
now it may feel safe because you're with
your family and friends
but over 70 percent of cases can be
traced to your households and small
gatherings
be new york tough stop living room
spread
it's up to all of us
living room spread living room respect
that's what we have to explain to people
it's not mass gatherings it's not
uh what it was it's literally
living room spread which when you think
about it is understandable
people change the socialization pattern
uh where did you socialize with social
beings we like to be with each other
where did you socialize we went to the
restaurant
and we sat around the restaurant and we
talked and we had fun
okay that doesn't work anymore we went
to the bar
and we sat around and we talked to each
other and we had fun well that doesn't
work anymore
okay come to my home
and we'll socialize in my house
uh we'll go to jesse's house on friday
night we'll watch the game
bring the family we'll hang out
and we'll have fun when you eliminated
those other options
socialization is not going to stop
especially during the holiday season
it went into smaller gatherings in
homes and that's now over
70 percent
that concept of living room spread is
hard to communicate because the whole
the whole orientation is
i'm with i'm in my house with
my family and with my friends
this is my safe zone i'm sitting in my
living room
of course i'm safe this is my
best friend jesse he would never get me
sick
it's not intentional it's not that he
knows
he was asymptomatic uh
i was with my kids i was with my family
that's where it's happening that's where
it's happening
that's why states uh dozens of states
went to no more than 10 people in a home
kentucky went to no more than eight
people in a home trump administration
cdc says you should
not be in a gathering besides your
immediate
household with whom
you are normally uh
with that's the cdc that's trump
that's why these people who want to play
politics with this whose politics are
you playing
it's trump's cdc joe
biden's coveted advisory board says the
same thing
the one thing trump and biden agree on
is
more strict than the state's guidance
it's no politics i mean you can't
dismiss
every health official every republican
health official every democratic health
official
president trump president-elect biden
i know better than all of them
okay maybe you do but maybe you don't
what a question governor there's been a
lot of talk in the recent weeks about
racial disparities as it relates to
koben but there seems to be one
significant in the city in which you
reside that seems to have been
unaddressed
really for the majority of the year and
that is inner city violence
basically there have been 124 shootings
in albany so far
this year the police chief says 96 of
the victims have been black
which i think means roughly we're being
shot at like 24 times the rate of other
groups combined
and for what it's worth he also says 96
of the victims or the
suspects and arrests have also been
black so why do you think that is and
what can be done about that
look we have we have a public safety
crisis on top of
the covet crisis on top of the housing
crisis
on top of the employment crisis
and am i shocked that crime went up
when unemployment went up and
desperation went up
uh and it's harder to find a job and
people aren't getting any
income no
am i shocked that crime went up
when we have this almost unprecedented
tension
between police and the community
no we've all seen the demonstrations
after
mr floyd's murder we've seen the tension
between the community and the police it
is real
uh and i think it's having an effect on
the public safety across the state
across this country
you see the same thing in new york city
see the same thing in cities all across
the nation
uh the police departments uh
are under more scrutiny under more
criticism
community is more sensitive
situations are causing an increase in
crime
uh police are more circumspect
communities more circumspect about the
police
and the relationship isn't working
that's why i said first state in the
country
let's be honest let's acknowledge the
problem
let's not skirt around it the
relationship is broken
the relationship between the police and
the community is broken
the relationship was based on trust and
respect
and the trust and the respect has been
broken
uh and divorce is not an option
divorce is not an option well we won't
have police
you don't have that luxury poor
communities don't have that luxury
look let's be totally frank uh do away
with the police
rich people will have police they'll
hire private security
uh it's the poorer communities it's the
working men and women
who can't afford to hire their own
police we need police we need public
safety somebody's coming through the
window at two o'clock in the morning you
want to dial 9-1-1 somebody
has to answer the telephone
and that's why i said in this state
every community has to sit at the table
bring the police bring the community
together
be honest about the issues and the lack
of trust
make the changes you want look
let me just add one point name one other
relationship
one other service that has been
basically stagnant for this period of
time
situations evolve services evolve
the way we educate our children is
evolving
right the way parents and teachers deal
is evolving remote
teaching whoever heard of that the
public safety function has to evolve
not every call requires
an arrest not every call
requires a police officer with a gun
a lot of calls are social needs
or mental health needs or substance
abuse
needs uh you know the the old expression
when the only tool you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail that's
where we are now
every 9-1-1 call requires a possible
arrest
and a gun no how does eliminating police
brutality though
address the problem that we're seeing in
albany and all the cities but like 16
homicides over 200 shots fired
those things are happening among
community members independent of police
and police are being reactive at this
point and frankly they're open about the
fact that they're reactive
because the calls for service are coming
from community members community
member independent of police getting
involved in issues
yeah but that's always the way right
there's always an incident
in which the police are not involved
that generates the need for the police
to respond
uh the question is the response and the
relationship and the trust
that has been frayed right now
and it has been fraying for years
it ripped after the floyd murder
now you can argue with the other way
why did it take so long to rip
i mean the mr floyd murder we had eric
garner in new york city
on video on staten island
same basic situation why
this moment did it rip
nationwide i think it was a combination
of all of the stress
i think it was covert and the economy
and young people unhappy
and uh a captive audience everybody
sitting at home and saw that
mr floyd murder on that video
but that's where we are be honest
and then say we have to fix the
relationship because we do need police
and we do need public safety but it's
time we come to the table
and we reimagine what public safety
is and i don't think
every response is a person with a gun
i don't i think there are a lot of 911
calls
that require a different set of skills a
different aptitude
and let's make public safety
a more responsive service to the
community
and let's air the grievances
what use of force policy do you want
what openness and transparency of
records do you want
what is the process that you think a
police officer who is accused of doing
something wrong
what should the process be that
you will trust that has to be talked
through
and that's going to be different in
albany than it is in buffalo than it is
in new york city
and that's why i said do it community by
community
but do it
are still reporting exposure risks at
businesses and restaurants
is clustering by addressing a viable way
to deal with this issue when
more folks are driving outside zones to
fewer places and how are you ruling out
whether
something is living room spread or
someone catching it at work
or in the community and then bringing it
home and i was also just looking for an
update on the cares act
funding and budget from uh the budget
director
go ahead so on the on the budget we
as you know we had a 14 billion dollar
revenue shortfall we still have a
10 billion dollar budget gap um which we
released in the
last financial plan update on spending
of the karzak funds
federal government gave us approximately
5.1 billion dollars
we're spending right now close to seven
billion dollars
so we're allocating those funds
throughout the year the karzak
funds expire on december 30th
so we'll fully allocate the full 5.1 and
then the additional funds we are looking
for
other federal revenue streams fema
reimbursements
and if not they'll just add to our gap
um
which currently we're waiting for the
federal government to provide additional
resources to deal with that revenue gap
so that's presently where we are we
still have over 10 billion
revenue gap we'll fully expend all of
the
uh cares act funds washington has to
pass a
stimulus state and local funding
vaccine funding or you will see
states go bankrupt which is what
senator mcconnell said
let the states go bankrupt
when states go bankrupt the nation
goes bankrupt uh i talk to governors all
day long they're all
feeling financial pressure
uh this was a political argument
that had nothing to do with reality the
election is over
businesses need help americans need help
we have to administer a vaccine
policy stop the politics
we use contact tracing data
we have about we have tens of thousands
of reports of from people who tested
positive who said where they believe
they got it uh sometimes they're right
sometimes they're wrong
but the base is so large tens of
thousands
uh that it is significant and indicative
if imperfect
vaccines i didn't mean your house that
will come into your house in general
i certainly
it would be convenient um leaving that
aside for a moment so the 170
000 doses that the state will be
receiving by
the 15th of december can you walk
through some of the other batches that
you're anticipating and you said that
basically the cdc had echoed your own
your own kind of
plans to distribute this can we
anticipate that those early doses will
go
to nursing home residents and healthcare
workers answer to the second part is yes
that those were the priorities we
established in the plan
cdc had this ac acip panel whatever they
call it
uh came up with the same recommendations
that our plan made
the hundred and seventy thousand doses
who knows the numbers
after the hundred and seventy thousand
we may get a modernist second batch but
we don't know what the numbers are on
modern
just the pfizer the first allocation of
pfizer vaccines
we expect additional allocations of
pfizer vaccine in december
and then we expect a modern allocation
as well so this is just the first
tranche of pfizer to new york it's 170
000 doses now
then we get another 170 000 doses in 21
days
for those same 170 000 people who get uh
the first round of pfizer
so it's two doses
[Music]
that are coming so we have general ideas
as the governor's slide laid out how
many nationwide we expect in december
but this is the of the first toronto
pfizer this is new york's allocation of
that so it'll be 170 000
those people will be vaccinated and then
the the second batch will
they second and third it's 170
000 twice it's not
half of 170 000 in other words they
they have 170 000 doses they have the
second
170 000 doses for the second
dose for those people basically in hand
uh it comes like 21 days afterwards or
something
more than 170 000 nursing home residents
and or health care workers how are we
determining who those 170 000 people
will be
well the first tranche uh will be
the uh who has the numbers on the health
care
workers together with well the health
care workers have tranches
they have delineations of uh healthcare
workers who are
in the most uh imminent uh dangerous
situations emergency rooms etc
you then have nursing home residents and
nursing home
staff right which is at the top of the
first tranche
nursing home residents we say are how
many five thousand eighty-five and
nursing homes
staff 130. so you have
uh 80 residents of nursing homes
and 130 000 staff
so you're at 210
just to do nursing homes and staff
right yes so you won't
get to that you won't